hi everyone I'm Abby from Abby's kitchen
welcome back to our series and lightened
by intuitive eating in our last video we
discussed principle four of intuitive
eating challenge the food please so if
you haven't watched that video go back
and check it out by clicking the link
right here and then come back to watch
this one also a big thank you to Alyssa
Rumsey intuitive eating dietitian for
reviewing this content I'm gonna be
leaving her contact information in the
description so you can easily reach out
to her for some one-on-one support now
before we get started I wanted to flag
that this content may not be for all of
my viewers so feel free to take and
leave whatever you find valuable also
don't forget to follow the intuitive
eating journey along with me through
Evelyn Triple E and Elise Russia's book
which I'm going to be linking in the
description below ok let's get into a
reader question dear abby i have celiac
disease which means that i have to avoid
all gluten containing products if i have
even the tiniest bit of gluten it can
cause a lot of damage to my GI tract I'm
having a hard time balancing this with
intuitive eating and also the judgment
of others who think that this is a fad
any advice this is such a popular and
important question now let's be real the
diet industry has done a great job at
co-opting medically necessary dietary
restrictions into trendy ways to eat but
for a lot of people with food
intolerances and allergies this is just
not another fad in the case of celiac
disease specifically gluten actually
damages the GI tract and destroys micro
villi which can lead to poor nutrient
absorption therefore avoiding gluten is
necessary for good health but whether
we're talking about celiac disease a
food allergy or a food sensitivity or
intolerance only you know what foods
immediately make you feel good or bad
and part of eating intuitively is
listening very carefully to your body
then gathering data about how foods make
you feel and making choices based on
that data just like I mentioned in my
previous intuitive eating video where I
talked about veganism and intuitive
eating for some people who have really
dangerous symptoms and experiences from
eating a particular food you may in fact
feel that this food is just simply
inedible so gluten containing bread
might just be not seen as food
or edible to a person with celiac
disease in other cases where perhaps the
reaction is less severe you may
occasionally decide that a piece of cake
is worth the physical symptoms even
though the data you've collected says
hey I get diarrhea when I eat ice cream
eating ice cream wouldn't be failing at
intuitive eating the key is to move on
without any guilt shame or insisting on
restricting or punishing yourself as a
result if you're finding that your
dietary restrictions are getting in the
way of you finding food freedom start by
reframing how you think about the
offending food and ensuring that there's
always tasty alternatives that you can
enjoy so instead of saying I can't have
bread try saying I choose to eat foods
that make me feel good which excludes
gluten filled bread but I can have this
amazing gluten free croissant try to
direct your attention towards all the
amazing food options that you do have
rather than the few items that are
inedible to you by doing this you're
choosing foods that you enjoy and that
feel good to your body two really
important elements of intuitive eating
finally if you're dealing with comments
from others about your dietary
restrictions it's important to really
address them sometimes it's as simple as
explaining to the person that you have a
food allergy or food intolerance and
that although you have to avoid certain
foods you openly eat many other ones for
other people you may have to be a bit
more upfront and advocate for your
health remember only you are the expert
in your body okay so on that note let's
move on to the video so in today's video
we're gonna be discussing principle
number five
feel your fullness now growing up I'm
sure a lot of you had parents that told
you to clean your plate before you could
leave the table as a fellow parent now
I'm sure the intentions were in the
right place and they simply just want to
prevent food waste or ensure that you
were well nourished so that you didn't
wake up a 3m really super hungry but
here's the thing forcing any kid to
finish their plate can teach a child to
override their innate hunger cues and
overtime children learned that the way
to know that they're done eating is
something when their plate is empty not
when their body tells them as they reach
adulthood they bring this mentality with
them only now they've got free access to
a wide range of highly palatable
processed foods everywhere they go and
disposable income to purchase them now
think about a family size bag of chips
and how easy it is to polish that bag
off when binge watching your favorite
show
first eating distracted can muffle your
fullness cues second you subconsciously
finish the Bay because you're done when
the bag is done now another example is
when you're satisfied from eating your
post dinner cookie treat but you notice
that there's one or two cookies left in
the package so you eat them to finish
off the pack the clean your plate
mentality can be a huge reason why you
may be overeating without even knowing
it but I can hear you thinking but Abbi
if I don't eat all the food on my plate
aren't i restricting food the answer is
simple no as an intuitive eater you
allow all foods in your diet with no
explicit rules or limitations you want
the cookie you have permission to have
the cookie you want a salad you have
permission to have a salad so if you
have a plate of food and you're full
before it's all finished you know that
you always can enjoy that food another
time you can put the rest in the fridge
for leftovers and have it another time
it's not gone forever and tomorrow will
be another delicious day but if you
restrict foods to only special occasions
like cheat days let's say your favorite
five layer lasagna you are going to want
to lick that plate clean because you
know that you only get it every blue
moon you have now placed this food under
a special category and because of that
you're less likely to listen to your
hunger cues and go overboard but if you
knew that this food is available later
let's say you know you put some away as
leftovers
it's easy to stop eating when you've
reached fullness because you know you
can enjoy it again later
having said that sometimes I get that a
really really special dish can only be
enjoyed in social occasions because I
don't know maybe someone special makes
it for you or you're in a really special
restaurant for your birthday sometimes
you're just going to overeat the key
here is to not punish yourself by
restricting calories or exercising more
to undo the damage hey yeah a DeLonge
lasagna it's not a big deal if you're
listening intently to your body maybe
you won't be
hungry for a big breakfast the next day
or maybe you will notice these things
but don't judge yourself and simply move
on now unfortunately because of this
clean plate mentality a lot of people
struggle to know what comfortable
satiety feels like this is the point at
which you've satisfied your hunger but
you're not so full that you're
uncomfortable you don't want anymore
food but if you had another bite you'll
be bursting at the seams the point at
which a person achieves this is
obviously different from person to
person some people feel it really
quickly and easily while others take a
little while and simply need more time
it's really based on a person's hunger
their needs and what their body wants at
that time so don't compare your plate to
another person's to undo the clean plate
mentality you're gonna have to work on
this for a little bit of time you need
to find a way to get away from the idea
that you're done eating when there's no
more food available to do this I want
you to try being on high alert when
eating take notice of every bite every
flavor every texture by becoming hyper
aware of the act of eating you're
putting your attention on the experience
of eating instead of the external
indicators of what your plate looks like
over time this process may help you slow
down and you'll start paying attention
to the gradual shift from being hungry
to being satisfied according to Evelyn
Triple E and Elise rash the writers of
intuitive eating this is called
conscious eating if we go back to our
last video on principle number four
challenged the food please
you remember that I mentioned the food
anthropologist this is a neutral voice
that observes and makes notes no
judgement takes place
so during conscious eating I really want
you to welcome in the food
anthropologist now let's go through the
phases of eating with the food
anthropologist by our side starting with
the time during the meal or snack while
you're eating I want you to take a
second every few bites maybe put your
knife and fork down finish chewing and
just pause this isn't a welcome
invitation to stop eating it's just a
pause now I want you to check in with
yourself and notice the following taste
how does the food taste do you like it
are you only eating it because it's
available
in front of you really check in with how
pleasurable eating that food is for you
satiety check in with how hungry you
really are are you satisfying your
hunger by eating this food is your
hunger going away at the beginning of
meal this may not be very obvious
throughout the meal you may want to do a
few of these satiety check-ins keep in
mind that you may not notice your
satiety levels change at all I mean from
years of dieting it can take many many
many meals and a lot of practice before
you start to clue in just like you may
not get to know a person very well after
one dinner date you may not know your
satiety cues after one meal or day
either now let's talk about what happens
when you're done eating now regardless
of how much food you ate I want you to
take a non-judgmental observation ask
yourself am I still hungry am I
satisfied am I really full on a scale I
want you to rate your fullness zero to
three would be like ravenously hungry
four to five is pretty hungry six to
seven is satisfied eight is full nine is
stuffed ten is sick now most people feel
comfortable around a six or seven you
know when you're satisfied and not
really hungry
but you're not so full that you're
feeling unwell so again if you go over
seven you're not feeling so do not let
this turn into the hunger fullness diet
every meal and every person is so
different that your needs are always
going to a banding on where you land at
each meal sometimes you're gonna eat to
just a four and you're gonna need to eat
sooner after and sometimes you're gonna
eat to a full-on 10 and maybe you'll be
satisfied for the rest of the day this
is just data to help you correlate how
you feel and what you find comfortable
as patterns in how you eat not to serve
as another impossible measuring stick to
beat yourself down with just like we did
during principle number two I want you
to check in with your hunger before you
eat and then check in with your fullness
when you're done interestingly
oftentimes the hunger you are when you
start eating the more likely you are to
feel overly full stuffed or even sick
when you're done this is why principle
two on your hunger comes first
because it's going to be really hard to
stop
eating when you're full if you aren't
honoring each and every one of those
body's hunger cues honoring your hunger
by eating whenever you are hungry helps
to build back body trust and makes it
easier for you to stop when you're full
because your body trusts that whenever
you're hungry again
you're gonna eat again that is just data
to help you make decisions in the future
about when it feels best to start eating
and later stop now I want to make
something very clear you do not have to
leave food on your plate if you're still
hungry it by all means of course eat
until you're satisfied clear your plate
add more to your plate the idea here is
that you're listening to your body not
the appearance of the food on your plate
although you now know how to identify
fullness you may still be wondering what
if I don't notice these signs and truth
be told that is totally normal
a lot of people have lost the art of
this from years and years of dieting but
the key here is to learn how to increase
your eating consciousness with the
following very important steps number
one limit distractions I'm a mom
multitasking is legitimately my middle
name but parents are otherwise you know
we live in a society where we are
praised for being able to do a lot in a
little amount of time we breakfast while
watching the news we work at our desk
while eating lunch and despite the
notion that we can multitask we actually
aren't as good as it as we might think
in fact when you multitask research
suggests that you're dividing your
brain's resources and attention
resulting in less efficient work sure
you can do it but not to the same degree
as if you were to do each of those tasks
one by one so if you're trying to become
an intuitive eater you really need to
invest the time and effort into doing it
start by limiting distractions around
you so turn the TV off put your work
away really focus on the act of eating
in a distraction-free environment if you
have different things taking up your
attention your attention is no longer
focused on listening to your body's
hunger and fullness cues this is not
about setting rigid rules or you can
never watch TV and eat food at the same
time but it's a good idea to test this
out to see if you find more pleasure in
eating when you're not so distracted you
might
be surprised how much more flavorful and
enjoyable food is when you've got your
full attention on it
number two reinforce your conscious
decision to stop it's easy to tell
ourselves okay you're done eating it's
another to actually stop eating one
useful trick is to give yourself a
visual cue that you're done eating
remember you're done eating when you're
satisfied not when you feel like you
should be done so for example when
you're done with your meal you can put
your napkin on top of your plate that
simple barrier between you and the food
can actually work wonders it reminds you
that you consciously decided that you're
done and if you're still looking to eat
perhaps take a second to just recheck
your hunger to make sure that you're not
actually still hungry if you don't like
the idea of that you can try putting
your food into leftover containers when
you're done eating that way you know you
already have it prepped for another meal
and it's visually telling you that your
meal is complete
number three defend yourself from
obligatory eating remember that you are
in charge of the type of food and how
much food you eat if you're not hungry
you don't have to eat this is always the
case when visiting a relative's house
there is always one food pusher who
wants you to eat and eat and eat I mean
we talked all about this in my holiday
food and body shaming video here so you
can check that out but like I mentioned
in the video although their intentions
are usually good you have the right to
say no it's a good thing to just
remember that you do not need to eat
just for the sake of being polite
finally let's address a really common
problem that a lot of people on the
intuitive eating journey have which is
feeling hungry all the time it may be
frustrating that you're already hungry
after like two hours of eating you
listen to your hunger and fullness cues
and yet again here you are hungry it's
important to keep in mind that there are
a lot of factors that can affect our
fullness they're both biological and
learned by having a better understanding
of the things that cause us to be hungry
or full you may also have a better time
trusting your body and actually feeling
your fullness here are some factors that
may affect your fullness levels number
one time how much time has passed as the
last time you ate it sounds obvious but
the more frequently you eat the less
hungry you end up being going to long
between your meals can cause your blood
sugar levels to plummet your hunger
hormone skyrocketing and you end up
overeating if you know that your lunch
and dinner are going to be very far
apart this is when you'd want to
incorporate some snacks in between this
allows you to fuel your body and brain
and prevents you from experiencing that
intense hunger and again I know this
will be a question but a be snacking
isn't healthy and this leads me to my
second point types of food despite
popular belief snacks are not inherently
unhealthy but of course we can always
make more satiating nutritious choice so
a snack that is high in healthy fats
protein and fiber will help keep you
full much longer than ones that are just
high in simple sugars simple sugars give
you a quick energy boost which is grain
certain situations like a high intensity
workout but without any fiber protein or
good fats it can often be followed by a
rapid crash in blood sugar levels this
can lead you to feel hungry really soon
after so if you're noticing that you're
hungry after a snack or meal checking to
see what that meal or snack consisted of
ideally you want a meal to have a good
source of protein fiber from some whole
grains or veggies and some healthy fats
I call this the hunger crushing
combination and together these compounds
take longer to digest keeping you
feeling full much longer
number three social influences
interestingly we eat differently
depending on who is around us in fact
research suggests that we tend to eat
more food and for much longer when we
eat in large groups and this makes sense
if we're by ourselves
we usually just eat our food and move on
but remember food is a social activity
so of course we spend time eating and
chatting and doing all those fun things
when we're with our friends however
research suggests that some dieters are
more likely to be influenced by the food
choices of others around them and may
purposefully under eat out of fear being
judged especially in the presence of
model eaters in either situation we tend
to ignore our biological cues for hunger
and full
when in front of other people my
suggestion is to remind yourself that no
one knows your body's needs like you do
if your friend is having a salad or
barely touches their meal it may be it's
because they had a big pancake breakfast
or if another friend is having a burger
and fries or polishes off their plate
and pressures you to do the same you
never know they may be skipped breakfast
and are really hungry for a hearty meal
everyone's needs are different so choose
a meal that satisfies your appetite and
make a point to check in with yourself
throughout the meal use the social
activity as an opportunity to really
slow down between bites to engage in
conversation and to check in with your
hunger and fullness throughout the meal
next let's talk about air food now a lot
of diet foods are full of air I mean no
literally like a rice cake is full of
air hence why I say it's a vessel for
peanut butter in my house but hey that
just means now the reason why these
foods are not necessarily the best
snacks on their own is because they only
temporarily decrease hunger the food
enters your stomach and kind of tricks
you into thinking you're full because it
adds volume but because it's lacking any
real sustenance you'll be really hungry
pretty quickly this also can backfire
because these foods tend to have a
health halo effect you know that they're
low in calories so you can eat a large
portion of them to fill your stomach up
but at the end of the day you could have
become full off of a nutrient dense meal
and stayed fuller a lot longer so a lot
of people for example turn to salads as
a healthy option but these two can be
air food as well so lettuce in a bowl by
itself is by no means a salad so here
are some ways to up the staying power of
your salad first is to add protein so
things like shredded chicken tuna
chickpeas kidney beans lentils and tofu
are all great options also add some
carbs quinoa couscous or have some
whole-grain crackers or bread on the
side don't forget about that as well so
olive oil avocado cheese nuts seeds etc
now whether we're talking a salad or
another meal or snack the goal here is
to incorporate slow-digesting
macronutrients so fat protein and fiber
rich carbs again we will talk way more
about this in the
so done gentle nutrition but bottom line
becoming aware of fullness factors can
really help your inner food
anthropologist determine the reasons for
your quickly returning hunger once
you've determined the cause you can
slowly incorporate some intuitive eating
principles to work towards feeling your
fullness for much longer if you feel
like you can't stop eating even if
you're full then this may be a sign that
you're using food as a coping mechanism
Iommi diving into this a lot more when
we discuss principle number seven so
definitely stay tuned for that now your
homework for this week so this week I
really want you to focus on eating
consciously like I mentioned earlier I
want you to take a pause a few times
while you're eating really focus on the
flavors of the food your hunger and
fullness levels and take charge in
deciding when you're done eating find
yourself a visual cue that you can use
to help signal to yourself that you're
done and be sure to rate your fullness
using that satiety scale again a
reminder that there is no right or wrong
with hunger fullness scale just take
notice of where you land before a meal
during a meal and after a meal jot down
how it makes you feel what foods you ate
and how well they helped your hunger
continue to work on these steps
throughout your intuitive eating journey
and of course stay tuned for our next
video on principle number six
discover the satisfaction factor so
folks that is all for today if you liked
it be sure to give it a thumbs up leave
me a comment below if you have any
questions about intuitive eating
subscribe to the channel and I will see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]